so
i'm gonna first say a few words about
backprop uh
from a biological perspective i think
as i said earlier it's it's the building
block behind
modern supervised entrepreneurs and
reinforcement learning it allows us
what it really allows us is
end-to-end training of very very complex
systems
um and there's still some mysteries
about it that we're
starting to uncover that allow it with
stochastic region descent to
generalize really well so they're like
really nice properties that we gradually
understand
um and as jeff hingen was
telling me i don't know like
15 years ago or something um
it worked so well and we don't know any
alternative is
blake was saying it'd be surprising if
evolution hadn't discovered something
analogous
that implements the same functionality
because it's so powerful
so let me go a little bit deeper into
why it's powerful so first of all
consider estimating the gradient by
finite differences
so you could take each parameter and and
change it by epsilon
what's happening oh it's not uh
capturing your screen
it's not capturing my screen okay
uh maybe can you click on that yeah
oh maybe what is this
maybe because i wasn't yet in uh yeah
but how is it for the
people who are watching it's good
okay all right right so
so if you wanted to do a finite
difference estimation of the gradient
essentially you would need to perturb
each parameter and then measure the
effect on the loss
um and you would need to do that for
every parameter so if it costs you order
of n
computation and you have order of n
parameters it's order of n squared
because roughly
this order of n computation if you have
order of n parameters
in a biological neural net at least um
so it would be like order of n
times more expensive than back raw and n
is the number of weights in the brain
come on okay so it doesn't work um
so what's going on here not moving
now instead of changing one parameter at
a time at a time you could say oh let's
perturb all of them together
with some random thing and then
basically there are many
variations but essentially they're all
around of correlating the changes you're
doing
at each uh of the weights these are
supposed to be the weights or the
neurons
of solution and then
seeing how that changes the loss all
right this is essentially
what reinforce which is the basis of a
lot of
reinforcement learning uh grading
estimation does
um the problem with that as blake was
saying
is you've got all of these sources of
noise
that are independent in a way they all
get
mushed up into a total variation
in order to figure out here what was my
role in this for each of those neurons
or each of those
weights you've got to average out
all the variations coming from all the
other events
and so you can do a bit of calculations
and you'll find that the variance
of the estimator will grow daily with
the number of
other sources total number of sources so
so you know again if you have uh
10 to the something uh neurons or
weights
uh it's going to be hopeless please
pays close backprop wins
uh and in practice i mean
so what uh
40 years well 25 uh 35 years of backdrop
roughly
okay and it's still there right
um that's right
and i and others have been looking for
all kinds of alternatives
um and i'll mention some problems with
it now
related to the thing about the why is it
so powerful like why is it we're able to
compute the gradient
so i mean so quickly and we don't need
to do as much computation and it's
not even uh noisy and everything
one way to think about it is
instead of having to try all the
possible directions in which you could
change the weights or change the neurons
you have this sort of magical thing
which tells you that oh there's this one
direction
which is the only one you need to care
about it's the direction of the gradient
and so computing that direction of
course is is the name of the game
um and somehow i don't think that
there's a
easy cup out like easy way out like
maybe some people hoped with feedback
line and that you could use the skip
connections to
i don't think that actually works i mean
so on the other hand backdrop as it is
written is not biologically plausible
uh the brain is recurrent the
uh non-linearities we use in f prop and
back prop are not the same
in fact it's linear in background it's
just that you multiply by the derivative
of the
foreproof then there's the weight
symmetry problem that blake talked about
the
weight transport so in other words we'd
like uh
if in the forward pass we use away wij
in the feedback connection we need
exactly the same weight going
backwards um
so the weight needs to be synchronized
and the non-linearities that are used
need to be synchronized because on one
hand we
compose with a non-linearity in the
other we have to multiply what binds
derivative how do we make that happen
then there's uh i think arena mentioned
the clocking
issue we're supposed to go one time step
after the other
in sync and the brain doesn't look like
this although there are some indications
that
we have things like circades and uh
and and slow rhythms that may correspond
to
time steps so it's not completely out of
the question but there will be
some uh mix up of signals corresponding
to different
uh inputs as well as another problem
that people don't think about there are
many paths like the brain is not a feed
forward
thing and uh it's not even
it's worse than that it has these skip
connections so
if you look at paths that go up and down
there are many paths that have different
lengths
and so the return time of feedbacks
is not always the same and so the the
information that comes back to a
particular neuron that is supposed to
carry credit
will probably be coming with different
delays
um so one thing i won't have time to
talk about but
uh i encourage you to look at is the
work we've been doing with
manimal manifold mix-up which is the
heart of
alex lam's thesis i don't know if he's
here
uh so that's there's a series of papers
we have written
and and the the bottom line from
biological perspective is that
it's actually fine to mix consecutive
examples
and it's a good regularizer um
it has all kinds of nice properties so
maybe it's not so bad
that's one of those things we could
butcher and it still works
in fact it can work better just like you
know sgd is putting a lot of noise into
the gradient
and it works better all right so there's
some fun things going on
um dale's law i don't think many people
have been investigating
uh that but i
i'm i guess because people think we'll
find an easy way with inhibitor neurons
to
roughly emulate um what we're doing
without the constraint that the weights
have to be either positive or negative
and it's not the same circuits the you
know the the the pyramidal cells which
constitute 80
of your brain uh they
only get to have positive uh
outputs uh i mean the outgoing synapses
are only positive um
and then maybe one of the biggest
mysteries which i won't talk about today
is uh how about uh like recurrent nets
for sequences backdrop for time
this is clearly completely out of the
question so some of the things that
you've heard already today
especially what blake talked about and
i'll talk about
are trying to address the the easy case
of uh
you know what's going on within the 200
millisecond
one second it's kind of a you know one
example
uh if there is recurrence we ignore how
to backdrop full time
i mean the recurrence that goes through
different time steps we kind of ignore
there's recurrence inside each time step
and this is the one that i'll be talking
about
but um but that um we may have some
uh you know starting some partial
solutions to this uh
you can look at the work on the sparse
attentive
backtracking the europe's 2018 paper
rosemary k
and others and um and
uh and we are continuing uh this work
uh so i think this is there's some hope
that
uh this uh with with guillaume lajoie
and others there's some hope that this
will uh
maybe partially solve the problem and by
the way i don't think that humans are
that good
at credit assignment through time
there's a lot of evidence for that
um so maybe we don't use background food
line because
evolution had a hard time implementing
something like this and we have a
you know proxy that has some limitations
but isn't uh a cure
so so the sap type thing can handle
sequences of events that can be
separated by
fairly long times uh but the number of
the the the form of the dependencies is
limited you can't have like a
many things interacting at the same time
um anyways
uh
huh it's a yeah last last nips
okay at all
this is that grading through memory
using memory instead of bankruptcy time
essentially
attention memory access memory retrieval
is kind of a tension
by non-parametric memory where you keep
putting things
that are emotionally salient in memory
essentially
and then you retrieve them and that's
where you do created assignments
uh the previous point which one uh
oh the one before that this one yes yes
oh no because the amount of noise here
is like humongous
it's the number of neurons at best
that's the issues that scales with
network size
here your noise just gets stupid
once you get to it properly
no no no it's nothing to do with the
data one example trying to find in which
direction i should change the weights
for
that example
but this is this is an order of
magnitude i mean many orders of
magnitude worse right so
here we're talking about the number of
neurons in the brain 10 to the 11
all right you don't see 10 to the 11
examples you're going to be averaging
over
you don't want to wait that much before
you get a good signal
right so it's it's a it's a different
it's just the order of magnitude is
crazy
um
right right so if you had just a few
um perturbations and in fact this is
what
people do in rl like d bar l works with
some
i mean reinforce and variations work
with perturbations but not of every
neuron
just the decision neurons
right and then it's background so you
get the action units
that uh get sampled in some way
so there's a bit of noise here now you
have to do some sort of
statistics with the you know correlating
with the reward and expected reward and
so on to get
uh an estimate of the gradient on those
units and then all the way down its
background
and so the amount of variation uh the
amount of noise that you're putting in
is
tiny it's proportional to the number of
alternatives that we you were willing to
consider
so and uh there there's also like even
if the number of actions
is continued i mean this space is
continuous and even if the number of
actions is large
if you have a way to prune like to
select
a small set of candidate actions you can
still
learn so this is a different talk but
uh in sab what we do we because you have
a large memory and
you would like to pick randomly one of
those
that uh is more relevant you just pick
the top k
and you back prop the top key and the
top can compete with each other and the
competition is enough to give you the
learning signal you need
yeah but the way we use it in rl isn't
for
every node in the neural net it's only
for the output units that's what i'm
trying to say and so the number of
independent sources of variation that
you're allowed to play with here is
small
in fact and also the reason why rl gets
harder if you have longer sequences
because now you really have to consider
all of the time steps times the number
of actions per time step
that's the and you get a reward at the
end and so now
the number of uh sources of noise is
proportional to the length of the
sequence
that's where it gets harder
okay so
a little other thing before i get into
more uh
the meat of what i want to talk about uh
the
there are a number of papers in the
literature on trying to approximate
backdrop in in the brain
uh that take as a starting point
something called predictive coding
which has different features and some
are quite interesting but
one of the ideas is uh
you you have back prop um
but where the target is your observation
so you
predict next frame and then
you uh have an error and
and then people think that what is being
propagated
from the sensory level up is the part
that hasn't been predicted
top down right so you have top-down
prediction and then
the prediction error is the thing that's
propagated and
okay it's an interesting theory but it
it
it doesn't work for a statistical reason
which is the world around us
is not sufficiently predictable that we
can make a prediction that's unimodal
in general uh
the next frame you know something could
happen
to the left or to the right or many
other places and so the
the conditional distribution of the
future frame is
uh has multiple modes so why is that a
problem because i
i'm only allowed to make one prediction
so if i predict something in the middle
it's going to be wrong and
uh it's going to be meaningless to use
that as a training signal right so so i
don't
so although i think there are some
interesting ideas in particular coding
this particular part of it
doesn't make much sense
well so the thing is they use the word
predictive coding
in a way that means not much
so i think it's important there's in all
these conversations you have to
distinguish
broad costs of models
and algorithms
yeah so the original predictive coding
was just as i said you it was something
like unsupervised where you make a
prediction about the next frame
and you use the error to drive some kind
of
learning in a way think a bit like vaes
kind of
things right so you have the error on
the reconstruction or prediction
but it might be conditioned on past
inputs
yeah i'm just saying that works in a
world where you're going to do
uh a task that involves a sequence of
deterministically predictable things but
it doesn't work in
in a real setting where like a video
it's not gonna work
yes
um yeah but but then you don't
e what i think calling it a prediction
here isn't
is weird right so i'd rather say we're
producing some outputs
and then somehow we're computing a loss
like there's a critic okay
and and we're going to compute the
gradient of the loss so that's something
i'm much more comfortable with
um okay so one of the things with
uh backprop is
you know there are feedback connections
in the way in the brain and uh
how do they get used and so on yes
no that's that's what i just said that
is not
plausible because the next frame is not
something you can predict
uh with a single mode in other words
there will be
many different possibilities and and uh
their average isn't a useful quantity to
predict
but but things like predicting the
reward
where it's a scalar and really we care
about its expected value
yes
i totally believe in unsupervised
learning but i'm just saying this is the
wrong way of doing it
so for example if you do something like
contrastive divergence
or the thing we did called variational
walk back
instead of predicting the next frame and
then
seeing you know how good is your
prediction you start from the next frame
and you let the dynamics of the network
evolve towards what it prefers to see
and the difference between the two gives
you the training signal
and that's unsupervised learning and you
can you can
you can do it with back bra you can do
it with uh
contrastive heavy learning which i'll
talk about i'll talk about later
but anyways feedback connections
um
so so so we we would like to have a way
to
uh to build up our system that um
that somehow from the start considers
the effect of those feedback connections
and
and short of the kinds of things that
blake showed us with the burst prop and
so on where
somehow the feedback and the feed
forward are sort of independent of each
other
you would imagine that they interact and
if they do that creates dynamics
and you have to worry about those
dynamics and this is what equilibrium
propagation was about
okay um if we take seriously the fact
that there are feedback connections then
it's going to change you know maybe
the first pass where i go up then the
feedback connections come in it's gonna
change
the values of these guys and now you
know somehow i have to iterate until
this converges
hopefully it does in order to um
you know i can't i can't uh just assume
that the feed forward pass does the job
basically
uh and somehow we'd like those feedback
connections to also carry feedback
information credit information
so so now i have a little appearance
i'll go quickly
so there are these approaches which
precisely try to avoid this problem
uh by looking at what's going on
in the pyramidal cells which are like
the main cells you should be
caring about uh is you know two kinds of
information are going to be there so
instead of thinking about one number per
neuron
think about two numbers all right and
uh so and the structure of these numbers
also suggest that the other like really
cutting off things coming in the basal
dendrites
and here in the ethical dendrites it's
like
strangely you know separated from the it
does its own
sum and somehow they don't interact very
much so
uh it really suggests like there's a two
things happening
and maybe one of them would be
containing the feed forward information
and the other would contain the feedback
information
so we had a paper at the last europe's
uh
sacramento ital that explores one of
these directions
and one of the ideas in this paper so
they're there it's it's
difficult to read paper um but one of
the ideas
is um
in order to avoid i don't know what's
going on here
sorry in order to avoid the the problem
of the feedback connections somehow
disturbing the feed forward computation
the way we did it in this paper
is we imagine that in addition to the
feedback connections
that go coming from the downstream
layer uh we have some natural
connections so what does it mean it's
you know nearby neurons talk to each
other
and they also project on the apical
dendrite
if they could learn to cancel the signal
that comes down
very plausible hypothesis and the idea
is that
when they manage to cancel the signal
that comes down
it's like if the apical dendrite did not
exist right and so it's like just a feed
forward thing remember we have these
feedback connections and they are
creating
complicated dynamics which wreak havoc
and so i mean in terms of computing
gradients
and so so one of the ideas here is well
uh we could learn these extra things and
turns out we have these
all these inhibitors that we don't
understand what they're doing and
there's like 20 different kinds
um and some of them will be good
candidates for for that job
so i'm not going to go into more details
of that but this was the the main idea
and uh uh joao sacramento did a bunch of
experiments trying to get
uh this kind of thing to work on mnist
um and he doesn't quite you know
get the performance of uh backprop or
the same kind of architecture but
it's reasonable um however
i forgot if you showed these results
about the fact that all of these methods
fail on imagenet
right so i'm pretty sure this yeah but
but but
but anyways uh mnist is kind of too easy
and really we have to uh
once we make things work on mnist you
know it's not enough we have to make
them
work on imagenet um
with toma minar and gaitanvinu i
explored a similar
path um which is a little bit
easier to understand the the math is
kind of
simpler but essentially implements a
similar idea that i just mentioned
um and we're going to have one joint
paper with uh
joao and walterson coming out soon
so now let's go to equilibrium
propagation
now equilibrium comes on top of a long
tradition yeah
sorry can you speak louder
one two one what
yeah so yeah you're right so this is a
problem
um but it's easy to fix uh
i mean you could imagine that you have
so it's a ratio of
four to one roughly so you could imagine
you have four pyramidal cells
which could be like sitting on the same
column uh kind of
working together and they share one
and averaging would be a good thing
anyways because of all kinds of reasons
there's a lot of noise the spikes and
whatever many of these models are
uh based on rates in other words we are
not caring too much about the spikes
uh as information carry carrying it uh
but but rather the average
spike firing rates and so looking at
averages over a bunch of nearby terminal
cells is actually a good thing to get
rid of that a bit of that noise
well yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'm just saying
you could maybe it's ten to one i don't
know yeah
so anyway that's that's a hypo i mean
that's a direction that could be
explored
through uh biological experiments um
but we we've done some different kinds
of simulations exploring this kind of
idea
um okay equilibration is
related to a large number of other
methods which
are so-called energy-based models
where we think of the problem as
uh learning an energy function
that has the property that uh the the
right answers that the network gives
correspond to
uh minima of the energy
and uh and so the way you train it is
that when you get
data you would like to push down on the
energy function where there is data
where it provides the right answer and
push up
in places that are where it wants to go
right so the network wants to do
something
its dynamics lead it to uh
energy minimum um but you'd like it to
go to another place so you want to
push up on the energy or the place that
it goes and you want to push down on the
energy for the place where it should go
all right so there are lots of methods
that have this spirit
by the way many of them are unsupervised
learning but we're going to do a
supervised version it doesn't really
matter here
but um and so
and so mathematically we're going to
assume that there is some sort of energy
function
um basis
uh where the network wants to go to the
dynamics
corresponds to minima of the energy i
mean where the derivative is zero
uh
and it doesn't really matter for the
math here uh
how you go there you don't have to do
gradient descent on the energy
you can also have stochastic versions i
won't talk about so
the equivalent fantastic version
i think also take
visits uh operations in proportion to
this is like very classical stuff like
in both machines and so on
now uh a clear propagation uh borrows
from
back prop a number of ideas but in what
you get at the end is something
uh very similar to older methods called
contrastive hacking learning methods
which includes things like uh both
machines updates
all right so here's what we had before
but now
let me try to explain a few more things
uh we need to make a distinction between
the energy function which is what drives
the dynamics
this is how the the neurons change
so the this equation means end of the
neuron
changes over time direction of
decreasing the energy
so energy is the energy is something
that is sort of a
virtual quantity corresponding to where
the network wants to go
and
why did it change myself
and uh i know now now there's also a
loss function so the loss function is
whatever you want to optimize
so the thing that we want to optimize
the parameters over
is the loss it's not the same thing as
the energy the energy is the thing that
defines the dynamics the loss is like
squared error
or log likelihood or whatever so so we
have
uh we're gonna have two energy functions
we're gonna have the one
that we uh use when the network
makes a prediction or is is used to take
decisions
okay so
so we're gonna we're gonna change the
energy function we're gonna have
after it's converged to a minimum of the
energy we're going to
nudge the energy function in the
direction of the loss
so we're going to add the energy with a
little bit of the loss so the new
energy function is old energy function
plus some small quantity beta
times the the loss and so we're going to
move the states
in that direction of the gradient of
that modified energy function
um and so the original energy function
we add a little bit so this is supposed
to be the loss
so we add a little bit of it and then we
get a new energy function that has a
different minimum so we converge to a
different value then there's a very
beautiful here
initially benjamin proved that again it
took it took him like four pages but now
he has like a half page
uh demonstration um and it's it's really
really beautiful
and it just says you want the gradient
of the
uh parameters can be obtained by looking
at these two points after converging in
the
initial prediction phase if you want and
converging after the nudging phase
uh and looking at the sufficient
statistics of the derivative of the
energy with the parameters
in the two phases and thinking different
tells you exactly how you should change
the weights um so in practice how this
would work imagine that you were doing
spread error for example
which after you conversion the first
phase you look at the outputs
then uh you have a target so what you
would do is you would nudge the outputs
slightly towards the target which is
push them through the perturbation on
the output
and now because of the feedback
connection that perturbation will
propagate to the hidden units and you
can have
layers um and of course you know
that thing now needs to converge again
but it's a small perturbation so it's
going to convert to something nearby
and uh and then when it's converged you
compare
two things it's actually a version where
you don't need to wait to the
end you can uh to do the update you can
do the updates along the way and just
because of the
telescopic sum it's it gives the same
answer
okay so yeah
i don't know
yes so we're trying
trying to get the energy
of the modified the amount of energy
so you have two behaviors i said if
you're
doesn't know the answer you want to
increase
that guy there's a behavior when you
tell it a little bit the
better solution that which is going to
be
right and you want that to have lower
energy
this locally so now it creates a slope
to move things towards the better answer
and you do it again and again and again
is doing this but it could actually also
be moving a bunch of others oh yeah
that's true that's true of great descent
in general right so
if i change the weights to do slightly
better on that example it's going to
make
things potentially worse on other
examples but that's also what
gives you generalization
okay uh so that's equivalent propagation
that's again the same theorem
not gonna and mnist yeah it kind of
works but not great
um then um
how am i doing with time i don't know
20 minutes left including
um no okay okay okay good good so
um so so there are lots of issues with
current propagation but i would say two
main issues that we've been thinking
about one is
the it still needs the waste to be
symmetric
i didn't mention that but it comes out
as
the need for going down the energy
uh has as a consequence that you want
the feedback weights to be symmetric
of the uh feed forward ways and and by
the way it's not trivial to have
dynamics that correspond to going down
an energy function
it doesn't work for any non-linearity
for example or any
okay so so it's kind of limiting i
didn't like that
so there's this um
symmetry is linked to the question of
being forced to going down an energy
function
which is a very strong constraint if you
think about it
most dynamical systems are not
gradient descent dynamics
right so just like if you take a random
vector field it's not a gradient field
uh
and it and this distinction does matter
uh
in order to get the equilibrium thing to
work you need
in theory you need a gradient field um
so we benjamin essentially had a first
result
uh suggesting how you
might get away without having a gradient
field so without having an energy
function
so now the dynamics is just an arbitrary
thing some
function mu that maps the old state with
the new state our derivative
and in order for the
equilibrium propagation update to work
in this modified thing there's a
condition now
which again brings back something like
symmetric weights
right so this is because here's the
condition it's more general
the condition says we want the jacobian
of the the dynamics
function
the same as its transpose so the
jacobian has to be symmetric
so this so that includes the
non-linearity and the weights
in the linear case it's the same in the
linear case it's the same
but but i think this is the right
mathematical formulation sure
and uh any of these algorithms
will work better with this so
i'll come back later i have a weaker
condition
which says something like we want
some products like this
to be positive which is
not as strong as because then you will
get that you go
down which is all you want
okay um let me skip a few things
and then the other thing uh i'll come
back to later
is uh can we
get away with uh out having
to wait for the fixed point but but but
first let me say uh
more about the symmetry thing so so
here's an intuition and then i'll show
you a bit of real math
i mean or at least the theorem so so
here's an intuition to explain
why this sort of symmetry thing comes up
and that it's symmetry of the jacobian
so so think about a unit somewhere in
the middle
called it hi and it's you know
there's a graph and it sends information
to units eventually to outputs the
outputs and information their
information
loss and then let's imagine we have some
feedback computation in the dotted
and so if now imagine the following
situation
i create a perturbation of this unit
only
that perturbation propagates up it
creates a perturbation of the loss
and then the feedback computation you
know is
going to be modified as well and i'm
going to get a delta h
resulting from all the feedback
so now the question is you know what
should
what should we say about this this the
feedback that comes that's going to be
modified
after i make a perturbation well
uh is the way to think about it is this
tells the story to some extent one way
to think about the story
so if you consider
the way you would compute gradients with
backdrop or you know the correct
gradient this
is basically dlvh and with the chain
rule it's like gldo time do h
right so that's if you want
if you were to consider the fourth path
it says if i make a perturbation
of delta h what kind of delta l do i get
right and take the ratio of that
um so
if we were to do backdrop this is what
we would like to get for the delta h
in other words we would like the
feedback computation
to give me dldh but the feedback cut so
we
this is something we would like right we
would like the
the feedback combination produces when i
make a perturbation on
l i'd like this perturbation when it
travels down
to give rise to a delta h which is the
same
as if i were to compute dldh the actual
computation of course isn't this the
actual computation is
i take this perturbation here and it
travels through the feedback waves
it comes down so now it's
ldo times the transpose of the hdo so
one flash
so i'm assuming that i'm going to take
the loss and i produce a nudge on the
output so somehow i can differentiate
l with respect to o then there is
this jacobian here which is how
the uh through the feedback connections
how the
uh outputs
changes and outputs propagate down into
a change in h
v h o that's the downwards equivalence
what is it
upwards downwards and
you can now compare the two things and
if they want to be equal you would like
the phone jacob and the package are
going to be the same
so so i have a version of this
where we say well we would like the
gradients no no we would like the
updates and the gradients
to be at an angle less than 90 degrees
and that can be summarized
into something like if i if i
were to make a perturbation
goes up and then goes back down uh
i want that whole transformation which
is like the whole cycle
to be positive
that's enough um
okay so that's one thing uh actually let
me
skip this for now and and let me show
you
another another variant of this idea
where we go a little bit further uh
to avoid the dynamics completely
so the problem of going to because this
other thing still requires
a fixed point so how can we get rid of
the fixed point problem
so i already told you some ways it could
happen
but but the general principle is
you'd like the feedback information
to not influence the feed forward
information so you're allowed to have
feet forward
and feedback but somehow the computation
that goes down
is not supposed to interfere with the
feet forward if you have that condition
then you can just do one forward pass
and one backward pass and you're done
you still need the backward pass to
compute the right things and so that's
what i'm going to be concentrating over
and how you get the feedback computation
to not interfere with the feed forward
might be like burst prop that blake told
you about
but now i'm going to think about all
right so let's say i had a mechanism
that allows that how do i make sure that
i still compute gradients
sort of like forcing the weights to be
symmetric and using just the right
non-linearity for things to work
so like is there like a general recipe
for forcing the feedback connections
to give me good approximations of the
gradient
so i have a circuit like this
for computation to be as general as
possible i'm going to assume
that the feedback here is not
independent in fact you don't want it to
be independent you want it to depend on
the
activity here if you want to implement
backdrop you need something like this
um some some information about what's
going on here
because you're going to need for example
to be used here and i've explored a
particular formulation here
uh where
you just linearly combine the down the
the the lateral interaction and the
feedback interactions
and the alphas could be anything that's
between zero and one
okay so so for this kind of setup i'm
going to ask the same kind of question
that i
uh talked about earlier so let's imagine
effective perturbations
and in particular it's going to create a
perturbation on the
layer and this perturbation is going to
propagate up
and then through the feedback paths so
either
you know here or all the way up and down
or some contributed
information come back here and
create a perturbation on the feedback
values
so whereas previously i was looking at
the case where the feedback
values were the same as the peak power
there was only one number from europe
now i'm explicitly thinking okay we have
two numbers turning around
one which more or less carries the
feedback information one which more or
less carries the feedback information
and and what we have here is a theorem
that says
that um if
we can make if we can train the feedback
weights so
the variation in the in the air signal
the feedback quantities due to
perturbation
here is the same as the perturbation so
if we make the delta e
i equals to delta s i to train delta e i
so that it matches the delta sign
then we get the thing we want so this
notation says
uh the change
that the forward jacobian matches the
back vertical
for any pair of layers right so if i
take like this layer in this layer
the derivative of this layer with
respect to this layer
is equal to the derivative of this layer
with respect to this length
we get this transpose thing that we were
looking for
um and then of course we can use this to
show that we can recover the true
gradient so if we were able
to make these combinations
forward perturbation then
then when we do a perturbation on the
output loss and we let it
propagate down we get
uh get these delta e's
that approximate true gradient
with respect to the hidden units
and the beta here is the amount of
perturbation that we're putting in of
course these are all like
assuming that the perturbations are
small enough that we can linearize all
of these things
um and actually um
yeah and actually i don't think that you
need those uh
so you move in the right direction okay
now in order to make those things match
you could do something what i call
differential reconstruction error so in
order
for the
back information to match the forward
perturbations
but you could you could just create
perturbations one way or another
track of the perturbation that was
observed here and then
wait a little bit and see what kind of
perturbations you get
on the feedback path and
just and update those feedback weights
so that you would minimize the nash
error here so it's like reconstruction
error
except that it's not the values that
you're trying to reconstruct
but the uh it's a differential thing so
if i make a small change
on uh the input of the autoencoder i
want the same change to be recovered on
the reconstruction side
and so it's a different kind of
autoencoder cost than what we've been
thinking about up to now
but there's another thing i wanted to
talk about which is
less advanced in in the sense that i
don't have
any proofs of anything is more like an
intuition of things
but it it generalizes it helps me to
generalize a little bit by thinking
about
well what if we don't perfectly
manage to get something like feed
forward or like no interaction between
the feed forward and the feedback and so
on and there will be some natural
connections as well
that create more recurrence and so you
won't be able to have purely feed
forward computation in the brain
so how do we handle that and uh so one
possibility is to be patient and wait
that
thing settles to a fixed point and hope
that with tricks like what i mentioned
earlier like this cancellation tricks
maybe
we can make that happen another option
or can be combined with that
is the thinking i'm gonna tell you about
so the thinking is
uh okay we're not gonna wait for the
thing to go to a fixed point
instead we're going to do something uh
like predict
how the trajectory of this neuron would
have been
if i had not perturbed the network with
my nudging
i call this counter factual
uh reasoning at the level of the
internet so let's say
you know i'm saying a particular neural
configuration and some group of draws
and predict
where the neuron would be
if it continues its uh
i've not converged right so the thing is
moving
but we can estimate things like how fast
am i moving so
i could the neuron could easily predict
with some error
where it will be in 100 milliseconds all
right
let's see the neurons were able to do
that so there's going to be a prediction
of where the neuron will be
all things being equal so if there's no
outside
intervention uh you know it would
hopefully do a good job breaking where
it will be
no nothing is a fixed point so so now
we're going to consider
two trajectories the true trajectory is
going to be this one
because now we're going to do is imagine
that there is an outside perturbation so
there's some error that's going to nudge
some units and that's going to change
the dynamics of course that would have
been because there are errors
they are unpredictable right so the
uh in the middle uh
is not going to be able to predict where
it will go due to that error
where it would go if there was no air
but you can look at the difference
between those two things
and what i'm claiming is that contains
the information you want
to update you know to get the gradient
on the
earth so um
so why is that well first of all you can
see that there's a special case
of if uh we are approaching a fixed
point it works
because at a fixed point we're gonna be
in the same place so you
just compare where you were where you
get after the matching
yeah so this is something that we are
still exploring but
but uh but i feel like the brain must be
doing something like this
or being really really good at making
the network
uh converge very quickly to a fixed
point and then you don't have to worry
too much about
um yeah the the
the the the error due to uh
not converging to the fixed point but
and by the way i must say that in our
experiments with equilibrium
why i'm motivated to explore this kind
of idea is because
when we train a clear propagation
uh if we don't wait sufficiently for
getting close enough to the fixed point
the gradient gets worse and worse i mean
the update gets
further away from the true gradient and
eventually you know and it hurts
training so initially doesn't make a
difference but what
to convert near the end of training
is there's a bias that you can't get rid
of unless you
wait really much longer and then the
worst thing is
this problem of having to wait a lot of
time
before you get an accurate gradient gets
worse
as you consider deeper and deeper
networks
because there's more interaction and of
course the time to converge gets longer
because the all of the layers you know
are talking to each other and not
agreeing and so on
okay so i guess i'm done
thanks
[Applause]
to your very last comment about time yes
first of all i don't think that this is
the case but
my experience it's weird coming out
i don't really quite understand what
happens if you have an equilibrium
i don't believe it for layered networks
you can see for lane networks why it
doesn't work yes i agree but recurrent
networks such as the ones you might find
okay that's so maybe there's a saving
grace
but my point is maybe that's not yeah
so i mean i i suspect that what you
found is due to random networks
and random networks are not
the kind of networks you want
like the kind of networks that you train
after learning
they don't look at all like a random
network they're like weird properties
and random networks are like too simple
and i have they have all kinds
i'm very very wary when i see analysis
of random networks
because i know like if you take a
network
uh either feedforward or recurrent just
after initialization
they have all kinds of properties that
are very different from after training
but anyways i could be wrong
other yes
yeah you converted as many things as you
want i mean uh
in a way you can think of it as each
perturbation might be either due to the
gradient of one loss
or there are different perturbations
corresponding to different losses that
you have so you can have as many
perturbations as you want you can think
of them each perturbation is
corresponding to something you want to
change some behavioral network you want
to change
no no the perturbation comes from the
outside of like i'm considering some sub
network
and it's trying to do some job okay and
then the rest of the brain
is telling it you should do it slightly
differently
that's what i mean by perturbation and
it's it's telling it to some units that
it's
talking to
so the perturbations are not something
from inside it's something
like there's a loss function there's
some outside world that tells me what's
wrong with what i'm doing at some
level that it can measure uh doina
okay
i need to think more about it maybe i'll
come and bug you
last question
uh yes uh so in in the the things that
blake presented with burst prop
they are both setting the nonlinearity
and the feedback weights in a magical
way that works
but there's some issues so first of all
it's not clear you can set it to be the
nonlinearity to be like
exactly the exponential it's and more
importantly
it's hard to believe that i mean we know
that you don't have exactly
point-to-point feedback
in other words if your i talks to j
it's not guaranteed that j talks to i it
might go through some other loop
and so i need instead to define a loss
function that's going to be locally
optimized that's going to make the
feedback path do what i need
that's what i'm trying to do here